hello welcome to co playing WTF a I feed
master from Australia and most likely
it's the flag head least l86 is the main
move takes a while down 95 Bishop g2
night c24 is the absolute mainline him
d 5 okay hmm it's an uncommon way to
play this open open this up the reason
is that I think that this is not played
so often that the c8 Bishop here doesn't
have a clear way to activate and the
dark squares are an issue here 95 is a
more just very directly pushing forward
what is what is what happens on this
let's try this first
see you create a 5 I have 95 I thought
position Bishop a force also a move but
then probably just couldn't be too okay
as an ID that g5 is not a threat here
okay quite quite clearly not a threat oh
I'm special pay for come on ah this
should be fun yeah this is the way to
lose games very easily just blunder
exchanges and it's a very bad position
on top but it doesn't do it okay um yeah
95
some interesting lines here nitey for
hands and things like that 55 I don't
don't know I'm Kim taking this hmm now
the voice is really down after a full
day of talking sorry
I'm going for c4 c4 c5 a possible oh
yeah I got 96 coming
that's probably nothing special this one
mmm yeah I can take take everything and
maybe be like that slightly better it's
there something else 96 is a little bit
more complicated maybe but I mean okay
let's keep it simple Luke checks would
be seven mmda porn up so probably back
and then push a for next
yeah I'm just pushing this porn and see
if that's enough okay I cannot take as
this is hanging with chick
oh that's if I didn't see
Wow shoot it's not so easy him
hmm Jeff very well defended I guess or I
did something wrong I don't know I
didn't know so I think I should push it
back and now my king is quick maybe
let's not enough to win
tempo time morning hmm we're going to
4th maybe to make it more difficult
femme to create a passer
still gets one I wonder okay let's
promote check I can probably check take
this check and do it this is now yeah
hmm kind of lucky that that I wonder
didn't see look 82 a soul resides yeah
so yeah it was a very lucky game anyway
we could have landed Bishop a for it is
just and it's also it's totally winning
or like it's not just I mean sometimes
you can fight with the exchange down but
here I cannot fight I have nothing I
have to go here and he takes it between
85 and black it's just killing me here
yeah okay and now it's still ok at least
I guess chan and yet I thought maybe it
takes to tick with the rook air at the
pawn I'm sorry but I know he had called
the play yeah absolutely yeah I should
maybe take the age you know what I
didn't see us I mean I such as this but
I didn't see that he cannot take it
because of Queenie five I think yeah
this is the key idea
okay this and I didn't see that move
coming the engine wants to play king of
one method was I didn't didn't seem
right to me he at least I think I'm I'm
okay yeah and he is in trouble he can do
this actually this is a good move just
keep both rooks here and if I have to do
this he can go okay to threatening look
after him so this is this is a total
wrong and when he took i mean this is
this is getting interesting yeah after
this is losing king of 16 3 king is
seven kindy 426 a 60 k 7 f 4
I'm not really sure if this is a draw
not the line that the computer gives
looks tricky hook like it wants to allow
this something like this and now this
this idea hmm yeah my twin might win
this this seems to definitely lose
because now he cannot prevent me from
promoting jab check yeah and that was
that was a win hmm hmm tricky ending but
this is an interesting point yeah that
you shouldn't take on f2 but but to keep
the roofs on this is a lot stronger
threatening this and it's also clear all
yeah this Desai shouldn't try I might be
a draw of it it's not nothing that one
should should should aim for okay well
thanks for watching